done a surprise draft for week seven
quick quick trivia question although you
got multiple questions right how many do
i gotta get right to this one yeah you
gotta get you gotta get another one baby
how many total yards did the new york
jets have in the second half of sunday's
18 to 10 loss to the buffalo bills total
yards well i mean it was 10-6 at
halftime and they i mean i don't
remember them doing anything i mean
i i mean i'll guess i mean i guess it's
anywhere from
10 to a 200 yards for my trivia question
here a little broad i'm going to say 12
yards i'm gonna go 12. four
oh
four oh i got it wrong how dare i didn't
guess four
it was the uh it was the uh shift from
adam gase to uh dell loggins as the play
caller although they only lost by eight
they were competitive they were right
they definitely look at the final score
it doesn't make your stomach churn so at
least they have that going for them
which is nice all right i'll give you
the first pick anyway since no it
doesn't matter go ahead i didn't get it
it's all right go ahead
there's plenty to go around here
all right first one for me i got to say
the new england patriots generally i
know we're supposed to be specific here
but
i'm stunned that's okay casey sims does
it all the time i'm stunned i'm stunned
i'm shocked that's a shock if you just
look at yesterday's scores and you see
33-6 new england that doesn't happen to
the patriots no they don't get blown out
especially at home
this entire it is an entire
organizational collapse right now and i
don't know what they can do to turn it
around because they got six days before
they have to go to buffalo and so yes
it's a surprise it's sad
sad and uh it's stunning to see the
patriots where they currently are
especially because
you know it was just a few weeks ago
they were blowing out the las vegas
raiders yeah that's what makes it even
more stunning right no i i'm i'm with
you uh you know what i mean i think i'm
gonna go with like the cowboys their
performance yesterday as my sunday
surprise i'm gonna do the same type of
thing i mean i know they were bad i get
it but to just be dominated that way to
never have a chance in a football game
against the washington football team who
certainly is you know not on their way
to the super bowl this year i mean
that's just embarrassing i mean in every
aspect it really was i mean i just
thought after dallas okay it's andy
dalton's second game they got
embarrassed on monday night against the
cardinals you know i picked washington
to win the game i did but i thought it
would be very very close and dallas
would show some pride i mean this game
was over
it was over before i got done with my
first serving of french fries yesterday
i mean it was done you were like they
got no chance they can't do anything
they can't pass protect they can't throw
the ball down the field and then i went
back to eating my french fries and
ketchup i mean but that was just
embarrassing they should be embarrassed
really
how many servings of french fries did
you two two i have two every sunday two
big servings of french fries with a
chicken caesar salad yes
do you try to time it out like when you
eat is it like after the first quarter
after halftime like i've got that rhythm
as to when i try to eat the food you
know half time after we do our meeting
before the the kickoffs like it's just
it's you try to have a rhythm and a flow
to the day all right people nobody
nobody cares about that i guarantee you
next one for me baker mayfield yeah
especially because he started 0-5
but joe burrow had 406 yards passing odo
beckham jr exits in the aftermath of the
first pass thrown in the game by baker
mayfield because for the second straight
game the first pass throne is
intercepted i admire the fact that obj
tried to make the tackle but he suffered
a left knee injury that we're going to
find out this morning whether or not it
was a torn acl or something else that'll
put him on the shelf
and uh uh very unfortunate for obj but
very fortunate for the browns to have
baker mayfield
wake up or i
m my niece who is a rabbit browns fan
who has suffered through the worst of
the worst with the browns was texting me
she demands baker mayfield be benched as
if there's something i can do to help
her out with that in that moment uh she
was singing a different tune by the end
of the day oh mayfield was great after
that rough start
and uh and and yeah this this battle
between the browns look they had a 35 30
game
on a thursday night earlier this year
they've got the the 37 34 game yesterday
uh it's great
it's it's just it just incredible 37 34
games yesterday isn't that weird that's
just not a common score but uh yeah
37-34
brown's win mayfield wakes up they got
to five wins
and they're going to get at least 10
this year they got 10 wins on the
schedule
i i i don't disagree i mean
they certainly seem like they're gonna
beat the teams they're supposed to be
we've talked about this last week you
know will they beat any of the teams
that we're not sure they're better than
you know right now the only one they got
on the schedule that way is the colts
other than that it's like okay we
thought you would beat this team they're
not very good yet but either way baker
mayfield was awesome yesterday
yeah
question answer and look we hope odell
beckham jr is fine although the
indications are any time you have a
situation like this and you see the the
body language and you hear the reports
yeah they're just waiting for the mri to
confirm it doesn't seem good if he's
done for the year does that actually
help baker mayfield by taking that
element out of play where he feels like
he's constantly gotta look for odell
beckham jr i don't think it does i think
i you know
i feel like they got over a hurdle a few
weeks ago with that a little bit you
know not to say it was gone totally
but i think the fact that they were
winning games and they were finding ways
to get odell the ball in a lot of
different ways kind of took the edge off
of that conversation you know the other
thing that you know people
odell not being there is going to hurt
them despite his lack of stats and
things like that you know the greatness
of odell too is the attention he causes
he makes your run game better you know
he makes it iffy on do we really want to
leave our guy one-on-one with him that
way you know he gives the offense some
different things that our defenses are
some different things to think about too
that way but
i still think there's enough weapons to
go around but i certainly don't think
they're going to be as good without
odell i do think that hurts them
all right what do you got next
i got to go with like the st
the steelers offense
just big ben on third down that's
exactly that's kind of where i want to
make it maybe i just say that big ben on
third down that was a sunday surprise to
me
i i again i just didn't know how good
the steelers offense was
and we've seen some you know inability
to put games away throughout the year
not that they put the game away
yesterday but they just controlled the
the football forever
they they really time of possession
big ben keeping them in third and fours
and third and threes and then always
getting the first down and doing things
like that the short passing game some of
the short run game they have with james
connor that way i think that was the
shocker to me about yesterday's games
the fact that you know tennessee titans
defense which has not been good
you know they just couldn't make a play
couldn't get off the field that way
especially in that first three quarters
and really pittsburgh's offense had the
way with him i know they lost a turnover
battle right the steelers but it was
like a weird it's weird to lose yeah
they lost a turnover battle but didn't
have any turnovers until it was 27-7
you know or 24-7 at that point so uh
really good performance by big ben the
offense and the steelers in general
i'm going down to new orleans and i'm
going to take a guy from the team that
ultimately lost the game i thought the
saints would win more easily than they
did but teddy bridgewater right let me
tell you and this is a full season
surprise
i i don't know what i really expected
from him i was rooting for him he was
5-0 last year with the saints this year
even though they've fallen under 500 now
in carolina they're so much better than
people thought they were going to be
they're so much better than i thought
they were going to be bridgewater was 23
for 28 yesterday 254 yards two
touchdowns no picks passer rating of
128.3 it's not often you see a
quarterback go into drew brees building
and drew brees has a passer rating north
of 110 and the other quarterback still
has a better statistical game but you
know br and cam jordan i asked him after
the game who had the advantage you guys
know teddy he knows your defense he said
he thinks it it advantaged teddy to know
that defense and it showed right and and
i i hope i hope the panthers can make it
interesting i hope they make a run for
the seventh seed
uh because i think they're going to get
better as the season goes on they have
plenty of games early in the year that
they can look to and and take some
confidence and pride in and maybe use
that to keep building but yesterday's a
game that it felt for a while like they
may win it and you know what
i got even though i'm praising teddy
bridgewater he took that sack that put
joey sly out of field goal range still
came dangerously close to setting the
all-time nfl record with the 65-yarder
to force overtime but i'm very impressed
with what i've seen from teddy and i was
surprised he was as good as he was
yesterday because i thought the saints
would know him better
than than it showed on the field yeah
well you know i think between joe brady
and him knowing that coaching staff and
then teddy knowing some of their calls
and things that show that they're you
know yeah it was advantage them they
kind of knew how to attack it i think
it'll be different the next time around
because now dennis allen will get a feel
for how that works but i'm with you and
that like we talked last night that
carolina team
is a little bit more dangerous than uh
we give them credit for on the offensive
side of the ball do i still have one
more pick left
yes huh i don't know where i want to go
here this is a tough one um i guess the
biggest sunday surprise to me would be
what at four catches 70 yards maybe we
should have doubled devonte adams the
houston texans but they just continued
to let that go all day long and rogers
just torched them that way that was
probably one of the biggest surprises
romeo cornell from belichick they
usually take away people like that that
was a shocker to me
yeah especially when aaron jones was
taken away before the game started
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports